it's a full a Capcom exclusive Yost
power 98.3 we're hip hop lisbon in
studio one of my favorite mcs of all
time from in my opinion the second
greatest rap group ever yes I gotta give
the first an outcast you know yeah but
I'm talking about my boob Nicola push it
push it to the building what I was to do
boule care man yo you could see some you
have like one of the best names in radio
history fool a cab I got that name
selling uh you know the first three of
Game mixtapes when I was like 17 and
saucy man yes haha ego hustler there we
government so uh you're on this tour
with fat man you guys are definitely um
doing your thing I know you dis numbers
on the forum record is but nan was the
video is crazy man you know I'm just I'm
just bringing it back to the to the to
the to the purity of hip-hop lyra driven
hip-hop you know I'm saying like numbers
on the board uh I did that shout out to
my man don cannon who produced it my own
Kanye West and shot the video in Paris
and you know man it's just it's just
about taking it back to the raw form the
raw essence of hip-hop man lyric driven
let's not all killer no filler I feel
like you have always been the guy you
and your brother have always been that
confident if I build it like when
there's always even if it's a time in
hip-hop where it's a whole lot of
[__] out you can always depend on
pusher malice you know I'm saying always
bring that lyric the lyrical content you
know the real hip-hop you know basically
that's all we really know how to do man
i don't i don't know how to really do it
any other way i sort of learned a
certain way and I learned it like you
know lyrics were the end all be all so I
you know that's why I sort of tough like
you know for me to like get into waves
that don't have anything to do with the
fundamentals of hip-hop you know I'm
saying not that everything has to be so
as always have to be that way or no of
course not but I was like this one yes
always room for fun it's always room for
the party but when you can we
merge it all together that's my goal and
I think I'll do a good job I like
millions is a perfect example yeah I
look at I look at millions i look at
brothels like big and jay-z who like
merged that'll everything yeah
everything together man and that's what
I you know aspire to be one day um
you've worked with the likes of you know
you got on with the neptunes for show
Pharrell and Chad you know some the
greatest producers of all time now
you're working with Kanye who is my
favorite producer of all time okay um
what is the the difference I guess being
in studio with each of those you know
entities your oh man I answer this
question a lot man I tell people like it
is two totally different dynamics man
like you know a lot of times I come into
a studio with Pharrell and Chad or maybe
Pharrell by himself it doesn't matter
but when I'm dealing with like Neptune's
production or that production crew I
come into a I come into a studio with a
beat already crafted to where it is and
the slide man it either blows me away or
it doesn't right working with Kanye is a
bit different because there's a you know
he'll get he'll give me basically like a
skeleton and you guys will build it up
well he'll give me the skeleton and
he'll tell me rap to the part of the
beat that I like and so from that
skeleton then i'll pick out the piece
that i really really love and I'll
probably look that and I'll write a
verse today and I by the time you hear
it it's it's like a full-scale
production it's a movie as a no matter
it's a full-scale production movie and
everything else and it's just like one
of those things where I'm like man you
know it's a surprise at the end as well
it also is different yeah I'm always
heard that about yay like it's like so
mysterious even if you're in his circle
and you're working you never know what
you're working on where it can end up
you know what I'm saying it's like it's
almost a surprise to you know the artist
you and me one hundred percent um
another thing I want to talk to you
about man I've always been a really
really big fan of the unreleased audio
fado listen man fab just walking in
walking on she came in
like I was surfing friend again he came
to this ball short oh yeah he got brains
are not addresses are you got a dress in
Arizona no way you can't make come to no
go ahead oh good you can sit right there
man you sit right there man ya know I
was gonna ask you about the unreleased
album a cuz I'm a click stand man audio
footage was I thought you know was
pretty dope it was always in my ipod
when I was young you know it means you
ever look back and listen to that that
error the clips no no I really don't man
I don't listen to the old I don't even
have exclusive audio footage and it's
greater than album as it was man it was
just one of those times where wasn't
ready and it wasn't time and that we
came out and I was that like 99 some of
the air and I'm you know at the end of
the day um you know we moved on we
dropped that low whirling after that and
hell hath no fury and every little one
was called lord willing you know me yeah
yeah yeah sure that was on that too of
course yeah yeah yeah what she was
somebody central at Comedy Central boy
hurt it hurt damn so uh my name is my
name is the album is dropping finally
man I feel like I've been waiting on the
official I mean of course you've had uh
you know mixtapes you've had the fear of
God joints yes but this is the official
solo debut of Pusha T this is your
official debut album and drop in July 16
July sixteenth tell us about this thing
man it's almost like your life's work
man is he's finally here you know I'm
any other day I like to let people know
that I'm you know the the fact that our
people feel like they've been waiting on
my solo album for a long time was really
by choice because see I sort of tact
this hope solo project as like my first
outing mm-hmm that's why there was a
fair guy forgot one wrath of cain
features a dissipation you know I have
like a UH I have a godson and his his
friend came over house one day and was
like man you know it's this new record
out with with Tyler creator and it's
this new guy they push it t on it right
on you get reintroducing yourself to all
these now man like if that was like not
the wake-up call that I got like new
fans and new people and then you're a
new artist who think I'm a new artist I
was like you know what I got attacked
this this exact way cuz it makes sense
you're doing all of you you're working
like you're a new artists you're not
have the matter
spun out the features got to man and the
last push one on the go ahead mansion
did you always feel to have a solo
project eventually or when you first
came it would never came to mind of a
young man fan for real I never was like
we talked about it me my brother talked
about doing solo projects but I was
really pushed into this bank my brother
came to me one day we was on a rope he
was like y'all wrong I told him I said
yo I gotta you know I got some ideas for
some new music he said to me I'm not
gonna music he's a matter of fact I
wrote this book and he gave me like his
book and I manila manila envelope my
camera you like read this you like but
you want do a solo project so you
probably should just go ahead and do it
but this what i'ma do right now right
and so I really that's how I knew I had
to do a solo project that's not my first
verse i have a road was blow for fair
god that's crazy you know and courted
like by yay like as a solo artist before
that or man listen right after that he
called me Ross called me Rick Ross
called me and said yo I think you need
to come to Hawaii to be a part of this
my beautiful dark twisted fantasy
project this is it's like big and yay
was like yo you know just fly out I was
in LA he was like fly out here I went
out there man I was hold still we can't
I end up standing one I did the runaway
in the soul Paul record and you like
open up his Oh lobby was like you know
just Labor's do whatever you want so
they got to a point where I just stopped
feeding and I was like rapping on
everything I can ran long you knows and
is trying to you know just just take
advantage of the situation but I caught
two of them and I was this you did man
yes you did it she had to push your tea
uh what can you tell us about the album
and I know Kanye's definitely evolved I
mean how much production did he handle
on though oh man you know we got a
couple of joints from Kanye man couple
joined from Kanye got a couple joints
from Ferrell Swizz Beatz my man knots I
got our dream Lord yeah I'd be a
definitely man got got the dream on
there i got rico beats who did exodus
okay um who else man don cannon of
course and my man sham sham hehe did the
ocean
yeah he did the man down Rihanna record
okay and a couple joints and watch the
throne but um man its own it's hip-hop
man his malice on the album no no okay
no with that by designer to here's my
design like you know we're not really
even gonna play with the clips dynamic
like when it's time for the clips to
come back we're gonna do that which will
happen you're definitely gonna happen on
the title albums will be called as God
is my witness whoo no blips out so you
know we know you don't leave already
it's already Allison I lose your idols
no to run no malice I don't know I can't
call them no mouth I think I'll write it
is what it is many got calling man
bye-bye no malice that's what that's
what he's going by and um it's just
gonna be it's gonna be great man it's
gonna be great I want to ask you makes I
felt like the last clips album it was
kind of after a lot of your guys's you
know close family got you know good guy
got um got caught up and you know went
away for a while and I know that you
guys are dressed a lot in the album and
I no malice I felt like a lot of malice
versus in that out i'm kind of like
almost kind of like I wants a predicted
him 271 hip hop aromas felt I almost
felt like to me like he was like um I
want to say regretful but he kind of
felt a little bit of remorse for I got a
rise you know the culture that he
portrayed etc um how was everything with
the family I know you guys have a lot of
your clothes you know close homies it
there are away right now you know
everybody's pretty good man and it's
more so about you know the wives and the
kids oh yeah making sure they're good
yeah you know everybody's good man and
um you know of course I'm sure you no
malice really write from the heart alive
so um you know if you felt that it
definitely was coming from that place
but um you know at the end of the day
man we still at it everybody hold ahead
and I do this for a lot of the mandate
like when they called me and tell me
like man I heard this verse you know you
was talkin it that you know that they
like to hear that man so that's what
someone from really good think of that
incident yeah I'm just listening because
one thing will malice y'all I you know I
check things online
scene one one thing he put up there
where he caught like his daughter or
something checking something more line
one thing that like I guess people kind
of like um like don't associate us with
it's like being regular people in
parents definitely you know having to do
a real life and sometimes we even
sacrifice that to be artists you don't
and some some artists don't have yoga I
got a family and I sacrificed a lot of
family time dry i doona mean so you know
I when I like even his situation I
looked at that am stepping away from rap
for a minute could have been for him to
you know just just just build everything
and on the other side of you know I'm
saying being an entertainer you know
saying I had I would do a little bit of
that with raising my son you know maybe
he sees five down he's going to school
you know but foot its beginning yes I
wanted to be there I wanted to build up
on you don't tell you I really want to
just be out on tour and just running
around every night I'm more Instagram
with pitches and Rick's and godly on
sale I got [__] on integrals in the
priority so you know I always looked at
Mallik situation like that to you know
yet when I saw it at that time like wow
that's deep because you said I family
they're not just you say your fault
bands did you know what's so funny is
malice called me the other day because
that same daughter is going to her
junior prom okay so you know I got our
limo for the junior prom so he calls me
like you know now mind you we know about
junior prom and all are you like I don't
even understand why I gotta go to junior
prom I mean running joke for you it's
like a lighter you're all mine is the JD
about junior prom on obagi we all went
to do whatever it was he's like real dad
or his real daddy was like man know how
long you get that limo for like Mandy
yeah opening the door like will smith
and martin and bad boys i'm surprised
when you're gonna tucks himself away 37
drivers that's where that's the next
stage of you know i mean a great life
for ya this is for having a daughter is
ill me like Evelyn daughter I don't have
a daughter but can you make
me a lot I got cool for those like nas
like knives daughter the situation heat
you know talked about his music and it
was out on this icon right cuz he had a
daughter shes and it ain't just yup it
ain't just your five or six-year-old
eight-year-old daughter anymores becomes
a 16-yard but people is going as nas
daughter special rock star hiphop age or
all these kids on one sorry i say well a
push of the new album is dropping I
cannot wait for it um cruel winter is
not ever coming out never never it's rap
Kanye's new album are you gonna be on it
I don't know yet but you've definitely
been working on yeah right i will see
okay that's what's up man um another
thing I gotta ask both yard because you
guys are in here together right now you
guys are each Pusha T to me is one of
the most trailblazing fashioned artisan
and then my do fab really was the throw
back here and all he says he's still on
his race just send trance Drake was seen
wearing Dada supreme y'all remember the
Dada supreme back in the day actually do
okay do you think what do y'all think
about the Drake Drake trying to bring
back down I supreme teach his own man
teach his own that's what he was trying
to do I don't know he's wearing it in
the video I in the new and the no
friends videos I'm resurrected something
I mean oh no it's hard for me to speak I
don't know what was going on right and
really see I heard a little bit has been
floating around yeah and I it's crazy
that is making such a big ripple in the
pond like I guess that's how crazy my to
look the sun but i don't really know
maybe maybe he has his own thing may be
the only maybe might have brought it
into it and you never know it's gonna be
a business move so that's it push it the
album's coming out soon man i can't wait
numbers on the board is that joint yes
sir go check it out power 98.3 minutes
yeah